benjamin hall is live in kiev ukraine
with the latest benjamin
yeah hi jesse look as you've just laid
out uh this war is escalating and it's
heating up as well the north the south
to east the russian forces are taking
more territory they've surrounded the
city of mario paul they're moving on the
city of odessa kharkivi's being bombed
to the ground uh and as you say kiev is
being approached ever more gradually by
the russians you know what we have seen
in this conflict though is the sheer
number of videos that come out we're
able to track this conflict almost as it
happens and there are some incredible
videos released almost daily on social
media
and elsewhere take a look at this one
for example
[Music]
just one example of how putin's
atrocities are being documented in first
hand and there are countless other
stories to go with that as well
another school was hit today in the city
of zotomir half of it left destroyed 22
civilians killed in another bombing in
chernarev while south of kiev today at
least a few children were killed in
various strikes some killed in their
homes some killed in their cars and all
the while russia is tightening the noose
on the capital the russian defense
ministry releasing this video overnight
that shows tanks and armored vehicles
now crossing into the kiev region and
there have been intense air campaigns
just outside kiev speaking remotely
today to rallies to gather people
gathering in european countries
zielinski urged supporters to keep
speaking out and he held a minute of
silence for those who had died
don't be silent come to the streets
support ukraine support our freedom
because this is a victory not only over
the russian military it's a victory of
light over darkness this is the victory
of good over evil
and i can tell you tonight in kiev we've
certainly seen more action than we have
for the last couple of nights uh the
thud of artillery uh flashes on the
horizon uh a short gun battle early on
the sense is that uh russian forces are
moving towards this city and it's only a
matter of time until they start bombing
it more heavily or they move in i can
tell you the streets right now they are
empty people are prepping people are
ready the defenses are up uh the
russians have made it very clear that if
they encounter resistance they will
crush it well they will encounter
resistance the people here are brave
they're motivated uh and and so we will
see that escalation no doubt in the
coming days uh or or weeks perhaps
thanks benjamin appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else